let me ask you
um to examine some fundamental
principles
of a particular thing that joe rogan
brought up to me several times online
and offline
okay which is that he thinks that
the tie that i wear okay is something
that
makes me uh vulnerable to attack
that you sh should be the reason he
doesn't wear a tie
is because he can get choked very easily
with a tie it's a big concern
okay my contention
and by the way he wore a suit last time
too uh he didn't wear it on the podcast
he wore it for dinner later
yeah i wore a suit the other day and i
had uh no socks on i didn't realize
yeah you're supposed to wear socks yeah
that's that's my understanding why'd you
wear a suit
you go to court no no and i didn't know
no
yeah i don't know i just wanted to play
i wanted to pretend i was an adult for a
day
okay cool yeah so uh so
my contention is like the jacket
everything is more dangerous than a tie
that's kind of where i was going with
that that's kind of where i gave it was
my first thought too like if once the
tie becomes an issue
like i feel like everything else is
already in it it's already an issue yeah
because the tie to me now without like
messing with it now is
is to me has some of the
similar problems that a belt does so
like for example i don't know about you
maybe
you can correct me but i'm not sure you
can use the belt
as tide uh
you know i know there's some kind of uh
guards you can probably utilize the belt
with but
the belt sorry when it's tight around
the waist and we're talking about a belt
belt or a keyboard it's not a g belt
okay sorry
but importantly it's it's not that great
of a thing to use
in most cases i would say because it
slides
it doesn't you can probably invent a few
interesting
ways to use it as leverage as control
and so on
but there's just so many more things
around that are better built better
better yeah and so for me the time when
people don't realize
i suppose are we trying to sell a dvd
here and have some some widgets and
bells and whistles because in that case
the belt is really important part of
what we do and i would really encourage
you guys to look into it yeah
uh if we're trying to actually like
learn something and say
like you said we're surrounded by better
options well that's the thing i mean
it's not obvious to me
that the belt maybe there's actually
undiscovered things about using the belt
you know i think people have used like
like putting a foot inside the belt
somehow
it's inside the keyboard there's some
this is a no punches ski grappling
situation yes
okay i guess so it's already fairly
contrived right but with punches too
like is there
okay let's let's talk about a street
fight with a belt that's like a jeans
belt like a belt clothing belt okay so i
get to take it off and whip them in the
face of the buckle
how serious is this street fight are we
talking about like they're nice
beat up or are we talking like no like
oh death like one of you has to die
oh yikes whoa okay oh you you ever
like i i'm in this situation all the
time
and there's a reason i'm still here i
had something
i said we started fighting the starbucks
kids we're talking about power
differentials yeah
beat up kids all the time just pick the
easy w you got to get the ecws you want
the
hardware i'm undefeated come around the
playground watch what happens no like to
the
to the death what is their clothing
that's useful
you know from my perspective for your
use or their use
uh both am i used to their use no like
i like how you want to take the belt off
and use the buckle to hit them with but
first of all how you're going to take
off the
like the belt well there's a lot of
effort involved in
unclothing well what i was figuring was
when they started to see me take my
pants off in the fight they were like
what they're going to pause and rethink
the situation for a second
yes and i'm making dead eye contact
obviously yeah exactly
nodding and then you know by the time
they realized you took a belt off until
you could whip them with it yeah you
actually
you're already one possibly two steps
ahead okay so fine
let's not talk about your own clothing
let's talk about their clothes okay i'll
take off their belt and hit them with it
no but that's that's much harder no
question but if you can do it oh i'm
maintaining i got no
i just did it
but the point is there's alternatives
that are perhaps more effective yeah
in my perspective this might be clueless
there's almost
no clothing that's more effective than
almost assuming the situation is no gee
grappling
like i feel like clothing particularly
when you start to add hitting
like every single time i start grabbing
your clothes if you start you start
hitting it's not like nothing could work
but
most of the time you're like why am i
not using my arms for something better
than what i'm doing them right now
right yeah it's very difficult for me to
i don't know in terms of just distance i
can't imagine a case of different
distances even like situations where
let's not talk about like like a
situation where you haven't both yet
agreed that a fight is happening
solid clothing is nice if they have it
on then i mean solid clothing oh yeah
like something like a good jacket
because you can snatch somebody on their
face down
yeah you know it's like if you if you
took my like you know like you snapped
down in judo like how easy it is to snap
down a beginner
yeah it's like so i agree with you
actually a tie in that sense might be a
really effective way to snap down so the
snap down is really powerful to
change the like disorient the situation
and give you a lot of different
opportunities for
you know taking their back taking them
down doing hilarious stuff like snapping
them down with their tie into your knee
and then when they come back up doing
this and you're already so yeah
in that sense i agree but not as a
choking mechanism because the confidence
is a choke i think you would probably
choke me with your tie more easily than
i could choke you with your tongue
probably i'm serious because like if you
get you can get like you get my back and
you can
put it around somebody's neck you know
like uh like like you ever see a die
hard
yeah yeah you remember when the super uh
swedish looking blonde dude or whatever
was was trying to choke bruce willis
with the uh
with the chain and then he ended up
getting choked himself with the chain if
i recall this properly
but anyway yeah like like that but uh
yeah i don't feel like i feel like if i
start grabbing your tie
you have too many other great options i
mean i do like the snap down that you
actually made me realize no i think
you're
good there was that i think you're on
the right path with it with a snapdragon
yeah particularly if you start with like
one of these like you know like
like you like you poke your finger in my
chest and then snap down real quick
oh yeah because it it also socially
speaking
it's not a threatening thing to you know
to
to reach for the tide it's not
particularly like a business setting you
know i mean
they'll never see it coming yeah because
i was thinking choke
but it's not it's a really good leverage
point because like grabbing a jacket the
jacket will slide if you try to snap
down
you really have to get a hole like a
really good hold that's a good point
because around the back of the neck what
if it's a clip on
how much of a jackass would you look
like you feel like and then they just
yeah
they stick you one did you ever see the
uh japanese politician or my thing was
japan
yeah it was that guy is so he was so
calm and cool had
like it was ever it was beautiful
technique
the level of uh of actually the throw
was even gentle yeah but uh yeah it was
perfect it's amazing well executed yeah
more of our politicians to just toss the
[ __ ] out of it yeah we need more teddy
roosevelts
exactly i like our politicians like
talking about fighting when it's clear
that none of them even
it would ever have been a fight ever
yeah somebody was saying teddy roosevelt
is interesting
i didn't realize this as he's one of the
greatest presidents this country's had
and he was one of the greatest
presidents even though he faced
no crisis whatsoever he literally willed
himself
like nothing happened during his
presidency he's just a bad [ __ ]
who made really great speeches yeah so
he like you know
uh this made me realize i was just
talking to a historian that like
most of the people who we think are
great need also a good crisis that
they've
that reveal their greatness but muhammad
ali right this muhammad ali i mean
in sports but but you know what i mean
like the circumstances what is greatness
you know i mean it's like you have to
it's not just your capacity it's what
you what you face right it's a quality
of opposition circumstance what you
overcome
so i guess what you're saying is joe
rogan is wrong about the thai thing
you know i don't want to go so far as
saying is wrong you know the man is not
here to defend himself maybe he has some
things that i'm not understanding i'm
willing
he has not deeply thought that this is
my main criticism of joe he's not deeply
thought to this
and the mma journalist would be like
ryan hall says joe rogan is wrong and
hates
ties and his ties they'll integrate
hitler back in there
somehow nice
you